[Musique]
bonjour à tous
aujourd'hui dans science clic les
mathématiques de la relativité générale
partie 5 courbure notre modèle
mathématique est presque terminé à
partir du tenseur métriques qui permet
de mesurer des distances dans l'espace
temps nous savons prédire le mouvement
d'un corps à l'aide des coordonnées du
vecteur vitesse et de l'équation des
géodésique mais la grande puissance de
notre modèle et qu'il ne fait aucune
supposition quant à la forme de la
feuille l'espace temps dans les vidéos
précédentes
notre feuille de papier était toujours
représenté comme un plan mais rien ne
nous empêche d'imaginer une feuille de
papier courbé sur laquelle on peut très
bien définir des coordonnées et ainsi
décrire le mouvement des objets l'espace
temps n'est pas toujours plat il peut
présenter une géométrie courbet dont la
courbure va entraîner des effets
étonnants sur les trajectoires des
astres
si l'espace temps et courbet comme une
sphère par exemple 2 géodésique
parallèle partant de l'équateur vont se
rapprocher l'une de l'autre
plus communément on appelle ce genre de
phénomène la gravitation la courbure
d'une surface est un concept déterminant
en relativité générale
il va nous valoir une définition précise
pour la décrire imaginons un plan
quadrillé de façon régulière et une
sphère munis de coordonnées de latitude
et longitude plaçons sur ces deux
surfaces un même vecteur dans les deux
cas on va transporter ce vecteur vers le
haut puis vers la droite
on obtient ainsi une nouvelle image du
vecteur qui a été transporté sur la
surface maintenant transportons le même
vecteur jusqu au même point mais on le
déplace en d'abord vers la droite et
ensuite vers le haut
sur le plan les deux images qu'on
obtient sont les mêmes l'ordre dans
lequel on le déplace d'abord vers la
droite ou vers le haut n'a pas influencé
l'image finale du vecteur par contre sur
la sphère les deux images sont
différentes elles sont orientées
différemment
c'est cet effet qu on appelle la
courbure
certaines surfaces sont plates l'image
du vecteur ne dépend pas du chemin qui
l'a suivi et al'inverse certaines
surfaces sont courbés c'est à dire que
le chemin que va suivre le vecteur
influence plus ou moins son orientation
finale
[Musique]
maintenant que l'on dispose d'une
définition précise pour la notion de
courbure on va pouvoir mathématisée son
concept sur notre surface choisie sont
l'un des vecteurs de base choisissons
ensuite de coordonner le long desquelles
on va déplacer le vecteur on peut
choisir deux fois la même mais également
de coordonner différentes
on notera c'est de coordonner mu est nu
maintenant des plats sont légèrement le
vecteur d'une part le long des
coordonnées mu puis nu et d'autre part
le long des coordonnées nu puis mu on
obtient ainsi deux images du vecteur
initiale en effectuant la différence de
ces deux images on obtient un vecteur
qu'on appellera grand air si la surface
est plate sans courbure grands airs nuls
al'inverse plus la surface est courbé
plus la longueur de ce vecteur
différence est grande
[Musique]
le vecteur air s'exprime comme la
différence entre deux vecteur dérivé
deux fois en effet on a fait varier
notre vecteur initiale d'une part le
long des coordonnées mu puis il nu et
d'autre part le long des coordonnées nu
puis mu on a vu précédemment que les
dérivés des vecteurs de base se
décompose en des symboles de christophe
elle après quelques remplacements on
obtient une expression finale pour ce
vecteur grand air dont on peut exprimer
les composantes l'ensemble de tous ces
nombres toutes ses composantes qui
existent en 16 version pour chaque
combinaison de vecteurs et de coordonner
et ce qu'on appelle le temps soeur de
courbure de riemann il caractérise
entièrement la courbure d'une surface
dès lors que l'on connaît le temps soeur
métriques
on peut calculer les symboles de
christophe elle est en déduire chaque
composante de ce temps soeur de courbure
le temps soeur de riemann caractérise la
courbure d'une surface selon toutes les
directions possibles
c'est l'outil le plus complet pour
décrire une géométrie
malheureusement ces seize composantes en
font un objet très lourd à manipuler en
particulier certaines de ses composantes
se répète et d'autres sont même nul
pire encore dans le cas d'un vrai espace
temps à quatre dimensions le temps soeur
de courbure possède 256 composantes pour
simplifier cette description de la
courbure
nous allons construire deux outils plus
performants à partir du tenseur de
riemann qui vont nous être plus agréable
pour les calculs
[Musique]
le premier de ces deux outils et ce
qu'on appelle le temps soeur de richie
le temps soeur de richie se présente
comme un tableau avec une ligne et une
colonne pour chacune de nos coordonnées
pour déterminer une composante du
tenseur de richie par exemple sa
composante 0 1
on commence par se munir du tenseur de
courbure parmi toutes les composantes du
tenseur de courbure on va sélectionner
celles dont les deuxième et quatrième
indice correspondant aux indices de la
composante que l'on souhaite calculé en
l'occurrence 0 et 1
parmi les composantes restantes
on sélectionne à nouveau celle dont le
premier et le troisième indice sont les
mêmes pour finir on effectue la somme
des composantes qui nous reste
de façon intuitive le temps soeur de
richie mesure les variations de volume
de la surface lorsqu'on se déplace le
long de sa courbure sur une sphère par
exemple le volume que renferme deux
géodésique parallèle va diminuer au fur
et à mesure qu'on progresse sur la
surface
[Musique]
les différentes composantes du tenseur
de richie mesurent ces variations de
volume selon les différentes directions
de la surface mais dans le cas de
certaines géométrie régulière comme la
sphère la courbure est la même dans
toutes les directions et on va pouvoir
la décrire par un seul nombre ce nombre
qui caractérise une moyenne de la
courbure selon toutes les directions
est ce qu'on appelle la courbure
scalaires dans le cas où notre système
de coordonnées aide orthogonale avec des
axes perpendiculaires entre eux cette
courbure scalaires s'obtient facilement
comme la somme de chaque composante sur
la diagonale du tenseur de richie / la
même composante du tenseur métriques
[Musique]
pour finir illustrons ce concept de
courbure par deux exemples concrets
le premier exemple est celui d'un espace
temps vide
muni des coordonnées t pour le temps sur
notre horloge et x pour la position le
long d'un axe
on a vu que cet espace temps est décrit
par la métrique de minkowski qui prend
la forme suivante les composantes du
tenseur métriques dans cet espace temps
vide ne dépendent pas des coordonnées
elles sont les mêmes partout sur la
grille par conséquent leurs dérivés sont
nuls ce qui implique que les symboles de
christophe elles valent tous 0 et
finalement les temps soeur de riemann de
richie et la courbure scalaires valent
donc tous également 0 l'espace-temps
2009 ce qui est plat il ne présente
aucune courbure et deux objets qui se
déplacent de façon parallèle ne vont
jamais se rencontrer
le deuxième exemple est celui d'une
sphère en un point de la sphère que l'on
décrit par ses coordonnées de latitude
et longitude le temps soeur métriques
prend la forme suivante
cette fois ci le temps sur mes tricks
n'est pas le même partout sur la sphère
il dépend en particulier de la
coordonnées de latitude en calculant ses
dérivés on peut obtenir l'expression des
symboles de christophe elle est à partir
des symboles de christophe l on peut
calculer les différentes composantes du
tenseur de riemann puis du tenseur de
richie et enfin la courbure scalaires à
la surface d'une sphère la courbure
scalaires est un nombre positif ce qui
signifie que deux géodésique parallèles
ont tendance à s'y rapprocher de plus la
courbure scalaires est d'autant plus
faible que le rayon de la sphère
augmente plus la sphère est grande plus
sa surface est plate
[Musique]
comment